hey youtubers it's Charlie so a bunch of
people were talking about this surprise
twist that George R Martin was teasing
with a character that's dead on the show
but still alive in the books so wins a
winner will have this big twist that we
won't get to see on the show there are a
couple really big possibilities but in
order to talk about them I'll just have
to say spoiler warning for everything
that's happened on the show so far and
everything through Dance with Dragons so
careful for spoilers for all that stuff
we're gonna be speculating about winds
of winter because that seems like where
the big twist is gonna be happening and
there's a new round of the giveaway
since the DVD is coming out is a copy of
the DVD all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so we can actually have a lot
of fun with this what's the most fake
twist you could think of Shireen
Baratheon dead on the TV show still
alive in the books teaches the onion I
tour finishes teaching him how to read
and gets him to start writing novels
about his time as a smuggler no really
though what like what are the two big
characters the George R Martin could be
talking about dead on the TV show but
still alive in the books there are two
really big characters one Stannis
Baratheon and two Barristan Selmy
Barristan Selmy is supposed to have a
POV chapter and wins a winner so I would
consider him an even bigger candidate
but the way they leave Stannis in the
books he's getting ready for what seems
like the Battle of Winterfell so we're
in a full-blown speculation territory
but it's possible that if Jon Snow comes
back Stannis Baratheon could win the
battle for Winterfell and free a
resurrected Jon Snow of his oath to the
Nights Watch I know a lot of people
wondering about Jon Snow does that mean
that his oath to the Nights Watch is
still valid because technically he died
in the oath is posed to end when you die
but it does seem like in a Dance with
Dragons the way they're setting Stannis
has character up is that he will be
successful whereas TV show Stannis was
not successful in his battle against the
Bolton's it just seems like the TV show
is gonna do a bigger version of the
battle for Winterfell
but there's only going to be one version
of that in the books it's going to be
Stannis that leads the charge it'll be
successful but then after it's done
someone will have to fill the vacuum and
if Jon Snow is resurrected he can
totally compel him to take over the area
knowing that Jon Snow is an honorable
person that he can trust but a lot of
that depends on what the future the
Stannis character is in the narrative is
the same thing that happened on the TV
show like him kind of seeding the
narrative to the Jon Snow character
gonna happen in the books - or will
Stannis be around to the very end and
end up sacrificing himself in some big
battle with the White Walkers
really what I'd like to see the books do
is give Stannis a more honorable version
of what happened to him in the show like
he just keeps going like he refuses to
give up and he ends up falling in battle
with the White Walkers instead of
getting his ass handed to him like he
did by the Bolton's on the TV show so I
don't want to see him on the Iron Throne
or anything like that if there's anyone
that's gonna be saddled with the task of
rebuilding the kingdom after whatever
war with the White Walkers ends up
happening and I'd really like to see a
more unlikely candidate and right now I
know everyone looks at like Jon Snow and
Daenerys is two really big figures like
Jon Snow if he really is secretly a
Targaryen then it would be totally legit
for him to end up getting married to
Daenerys and then ruling over the
kingdom but it sounds a little cliche
it's like the obvious ending to be a
little more interesting if Tyrion were
left to rebuild the Kingdom and George
our Martin has said numerous times
deterrence his favorite character that
doesn't guarantee that he's gonna
survive but I do think you know whatever
he ends up doing he will be around to
the very end to see what ends up
happening in the aftermath so just a
recap I think the big twist that he was
talking about the most likely candidate
for that person is Stannis Baratheon but
jumping over into the east another big
possibility for that twist is Barristan
Selmy not quite as likely as a Stannis
Baratheon twist but still if he's gonna
be a POV character he's gonna be pretty
huge I don't know if it'd be as big of a
WTF twist but there's the second battle
of marine that they've been teasing for
winds of winter like the first battle of
marine is when Daenerys took it there's
this big battle
she took Marine now she's stuck on her
own dealing with Dothraki and her small
council led by Barristan Selmy is stuck
in marine to deal with the current
situation
there's the bloody flux and there's the
army from Yong Chi that's marching on
them remember even though Daenerys is
largely pacified slavers Bay the minute
she leaves a big city all the old rats
just rushed right back in so slavers Bay
is still just as big a problem as it was
two seasons ago in the books Tyrion
hasn't become part of the small Council
yet he just arrives in Mereen so he's
relatively new to the area but he
arrives as the bloody flux is becoming a
really big problem but because of what
Barristan Sami has already been doing in
Mereen it's starting to look more like a
Daenerys version of King's Landing she
has her own Queen's Guard there newly
anointed nights that Barristan Selmy
will lead so he could have this giant
victory in the Second Battle of murine
that would be a big twist that the show
is not going to be able to do because
he's dead on the TV show what are some
other possibilities for characters that
are dead on the TV show but alive in the
books
well there's Joe
there's mance rayder what's going on
with them Jojen is kind of stationary
right now so I'm not expecting a big WTF
twist from him Mance Rayder was
glamoured by Melisandre to infiltrate
Winterfell there could be some big WTF
twists he could wind up killing one of
the Bolton's as part of this larger
battle for Winterfell Myrcella is still
alive in the books she was originally
betrothed to trystane but they're making
arrangements the Lannisters have been
making arrangements to bring her back to
King's Landing so that seems like it's
gonna be no envoy not really expecting a
giant WTF twist from her it would be
bigger than anything that Stannis or
Barristan Selmy could do but let me know
in the comments who do you think that
George are Martin was talking about when
he said that a character that's still
alive in the books is gonna have some
big twist that we won't get to see on
the show in what do you think that that
twist is going to be remember this is
just speculation so technically I don't
consider it spoilers but you do have to
talk about stuff that's already happened
in the books while you guys figure that
out I'll say congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner remember it's for
a season 5 DVD or blu-ray you know
whichever you guys want Kady list be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact info and yes I do think that
they're gonna be dropping the first big
full trailer when the DVD is released so
probably in two weeks but they might
drop a few teasers for that before that
happens it's gonna be a lot of fun we're
still on trailer watch big-time while
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn all about
the long night and like a brief history
of Westeros in the east and you can
click here for all my season 6 teaser
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you